G1
O
Zig Zag n'obtient pas la pleine charge du monde
de ces chargements quittant le bateau par le
la cargaison du monde descend du bateau pour rester
suivi de la charge du monde saigné
que c'était des charges à graver à la charge
d'un record avec les voitures partageant bien
venir le désir me prend à toi
juste en pensée pour demander comment éviter
dans votre Ares était la ville ici à partir de
ipanema
pas besoin d'être un garçon pour ravir
autour de vous
un ne sait pas tout cela pour vous de cela
un seul voyage semble être lorsque vous
Sarney
qu'il a l'air de vouloir votre
beaucoup trop
aussi alors bien je chante
aussi alors vient tellement
puis s'embrasser et
également
La voisine de Mara de Welcome to saudade
EA ira si seulement en pensée j'arrive
proche à éviter dans votre Ares est de
la vie au jour j'ai demandé
panemar n'a même pas besoin d'être un garçon pour
plaisir autour de vous
regardez toute cette classe, êtes-vous celui-là?
déjà la vie astrale qu'on semble être quand
vous y entrez
qu'il semble vouloir tellement ton chemin
également
aussi embrasser l'écran n'essayez pas
embrasser
moi aussi je vais très bien
puis s'embrasser aussi
oreille
Auberge d'Ipanema
et dans la région
oreille
ipanema
aller et
toujours participer ça paie le monde
selon
Charge du serveur AM